right and uh please be patient with us
while we get our
LinkedIn live stream going
will take me about 30 seconds
and we're almost there
yeah
great and Welcome to our LinkedIn live
audience our YouTube live audience and
also
to everyone who's here live with us on
our WebEx platform
my name is Stuart Creek I'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn I'm here
with put yourself some Nani who is
a software engineer too at GitHub and
she'll be talking about her interview
tips
land software engineering job
and she'll be talking about that from
both perspective of somebody who
recently
uh going to GitHub got a
new position
and also from the perspective of
somebody who interviews people for her
team so
if you're on the WebEx
touch form please put your questions for
puji into the Q a panel
um you can also put in chat we'll be
looking at that from time to time but we
will be taking the questions in a q a
segment toward the end of the webinar
and
if you are on the streaming platforms
you can put questions into your comment
box
we'll also have a couple of questions
for you so we'll start with this one
it's a two-part question for you
so basically just to get a feel for
who's in the audience how much work
experience do you have not in software
particularly or not in any particular
field but how much work experience
um basically after graduation do you
have
and we're also asking a check-in
question about how people are holding up
it's been a weird three years with the
pandemic with lockdowns with work from
home
with surges coming and going so we'd
like to check to see how people are
doing
give you another 10 seconds
and
so uh about half the audience or folks
who are still uh in school
um another quarter are people with the
two years or less experience so this is
a heavily weighted towards people who
are new and looking for
um
first jobs or first promotions so
that gives you an idea of Puja who who
we're talking to today so let me
get off the screen a little about
yourself I'm going to let you introduce
yourself
um and talk about your background and
experience before we start the
conversation
sure thanks to it uh hey hi everyone I'm
Pooja sabnani I'm currently working as a
software engineer too at GitHub and
prior to that I was at Bogan Stanley I
have a total of a couple of months more
than four years of experience and mainly
towards uh back-end Technologies and
distributed systems but I've had a
little bit of exposure with AIML and
front-end Technologies as well and I
graduated from nit trichy with Masters
in communication applications and yeah
that's about me looking forward to the
webinar today
okay
so we don't need to keep staring at
slides
but I did want to start off by by
asking you what um what prompted you to
make the change from Morgan Stanley
to GitHub what was what was the driver
there all right so I had roughly
completed around three years at Morgan
Stanley and Morgan Stanley I was in
fintech domain right so the Technologies
I had become pretty comfortable and
familiar with the Technologies in Morgan
Stanley and I just uh like the
recruiters used to reach out you know
just passively so I started giving it a
on off thought that uh I mean probably I
should explore different domains or
different Technologies to you know uh
get more exposure and grow more as a
software engineer basically so I thought
like probably it's time for a switch
because I had gotten too comfortable
with the Technologies and domain at my
previous company
okay and it's been uh pintech is a a
really exciting emerging field so when
you were it Morgan Stanley what were you
at the you know the new Cutting Edge of
uh fintech uh automated
credit decisions and and
instant lending and things like that or
where was it more traditional uh
Financial applications so it was more
traditional Financial applications but
technology wise we were using a lot of
this Technologies like Kafka and
microservices architecture so uh domain
wise it was traditional because we are
like the users were the financial
analysts and we were actually just the
developers who were doing it so a little
bit of knowledge of the domain was
required because you need to understand
for implementation purposes and uh the
product right so that was needed but uh
it was an old school one as well
and Morgan Stanley is
I think the largest Investment Bank in
the world maybe not the largest private
investor in the world
um but um you know traditional Finance
so when you looked at opportunities you
mentioned that recruiters had been
contacting you
um was that the thing that tipped you
over where you said here's a recruiter
opportunity I really want to pursue this
one or was that more the recruiters got
you thinking about it and then you
looked other
platforms for the job I think the latter
because uh the recruiters got me
thinking about uh starting to explore uh
more that you know how do I what other
roles can I take up that can help me
grow in my career right so uh definitely
I didn't go ahead with any of the
opportunities which were coming to me
with recruiters and uh once I convinced
myself or decided that yeah I am looking
for a switch then I started applying
elsewhere and uh gave multiple
interviews and everything but that was a
starting point which got me thinking
that I should start looking for uh or
exploring new roles as well
what what are some of the the places
that you started looking what are some
of the platforms you use or or tools you
use to to look for that new opportunity
yeah so uh one of other first and
foremost most important thing is I
created a resume and uh it has to be ATS
friendly so that uh it can be processed
and you can get uh interview calls then
I started applying on Insta hire uh then
I started I uploaded my uh resume on
naukri.com I uploaded on LinkedIn and uh
so whenever I used to apply on hundreds
of applications on Insta hire LinkedIn
but I used to get callbacks from only
like you know five or seven out of 100
right and then I started uh contacting
my friends as well uh that if they were
working in multiple companies or my
college batchmates or anybody I had
known in my previous company as well so
if I asked them for referrals as well
and
um so yeah that is how I went about a
mix of you know hiring platforms plus uh
referrals and
um that's about it yeah
yeah
you
get the first Contact is just we'll talk
a little bit more about the resume
because that's important you mentioned a
really important aspect of making sure
your resume gets through that first
filter but so get through the filter it
gets in front of a person they like it
and they give you a call
what are the the
what's that first round of interviewing
that gets you into the process with the
company
after the application you mean after
applying to calls you back
either a recruiter calls you back or the
internal um you know hiring manager
calls you back yeah okay so sometimes
there is a phone screening round to
understand about your work experience uh
either the recruiter calls your hiring
manager calls you uh they understand how
much experience you have or there's a
just a quick you know a basic casual
conversation to understand your
experience or what you're looking for
and how you would fit for the roles that
they are looking out for so once that
match is done basically uh then I think
they move forward with the interview
sets calls for interviews basically so
that initial call is basically a phone
screening or just to check the interest
and matching of the role
yeah now if you think back to when you
were
hiring into Morgan Stanley and that was
one of your first roles out of
university is that correct that's right
that's right so how did you answer the
question about experience what were
what's different for somebody who's
straight out of school versus somebody
who has uh several years of experience
as you do right so uh the process at
University when I was interviewing for
Morgan Stanley was that uh first
initially all the students had to give
an online test and uh once that online
test was cleared then basically uh if
you uh like pass the cutoff round or
something there are a set of cut-off
marks so if you pass that then you're
called for interview and then when they
asked about you know uh there are a lot
of situations where they ask about uh
what are your interests because
obviously my degree was my course was a
technical course so they asked about
what all you have done in college and
they ask you about those subjects and
they ask you about the company as well
so it is important to research about the
company whether you're at college or
whether you're a experienced person and
then they ask you about a lot of other
things like have you had experiences
with you know leadership skills or team
leading and team collaboration and and a
few technical stuff that they are
looking for so company which comes from
a database management domain uh so they
usually ask focus more on DB questions a
company like Morgan Stanley they focus
more on the algorithms part of it so
they try to gauge that out of the
candidate
yeah
that's really important for for folks to
know the behalf of our audience that are
still in schools that there is a pathway
for you
a lot of people
ask about well what do I tell a
recruiter or a hiring manager about my
experience if I haven't got any but
there will be a story for you to tell
and that's important
um
projects or college projects right they
talk about that as an experience because
it might not be a real world experience
but that projects that they've built
they learned something out of it right
so they got some hands-on experience
with the technology so they talk about
the projects and what they did during
the college right so that is something
that they can showcase as their college
experience
yeah and and that also brings up the
notion of uh
Advantage you have if you're in the
software engineering domain is that you
have access to things like hackathons
and
open source projects and that type of
thing where you can
gain some demonstrable experience uh
even if you don't have a job in that
particular field yet so that's a good
thing but now
in this most recent
hiring experience you of course had your
background
experience you could point to for GitHub
what What
attracted you to GitHub because that
that's a
kind of a meta platform for people who
are in software development
correct but yeah
so uh from moving from a fintech domain
basically to uh one of my your first
initial goals was to try out product
based companies uh when GitHub came
along then I thought that you know I
have been an avid user of GitHub as a
platform as a developer right and one of
the thought processes with GitHub was
that I've heard really great uh fun
culture and the thing is that the
technologies that they use as a user of
GitHub I really found that very
dependable and very you know useful as a
developer so the notion of developing
for the developers if I join GitHub then
I get to develop for those developers
right yeah it would be very impactful
the impact that GitHub has for
developers is very uh you know High
based impact so that attracted me a lot
that the impact I would have on the
users right I can say that people are
using my features that I'm actually
developing at GitHub right so there are
multiple developers professionals that
would be using so the impact that I
would create and the culture sort of
attracted me towards GitHub
and that's that's a great point about a
job search is that
it
some people are not as motivated by the
sense of accomplishment they're more
motivated by you know simply doing a job
and getting paid but I think most people
go into engineering because we like to
make things my background is engineering
too and we like to solve problems and we
like the idea that when we solve a
problem we've helped somebody or that
the solution we've created is going to
be used by someone yeah and so
um that's a thing that people should
keep in mind when they're looking at job
opportunities is
one of the things what you want to
evaluate about a company is
how will your work make a difference
there and will it be valued yeah
sometimes it's frustrating if you're in
a
situation where
either your work is
kind of
taken for granted or else sometimes
situations that have frustrated me work
I did something I thought was pretty
useful and important and it basically
they said well thanks but we don't
really actually need that or we decided
against it or something like that so
um that's that's one of the areas of job
satisfaction people want to get but so
you've gone through so we started off
with the phone screening and then
um what's the next thing that happens
after a phone screening what what's that
first face-to-face interview right so uh
phones can be an online test as well or
either ways after the phone screen there
can be an online test as well uh an
online test for different companies it
varies differently like some of them may
have DSA questions to be solved in 45
minutes some of them may have like you
know a back-end code that you need to
write uh for uh basically you know you
have an API you just need to integrate
and write it in your own preferred
language and all and I'm just sharing
this based on my experiences that the
employees that are given and some of
them might have a take home assignment
like you know they'll give you a problem
statement and you're supposed to submit
uh you know a solution for that so most
of the companies which are moving away
from DSA algorithm which was very basic
earlier they are starting with take-home
assignments or machine coding ground to
understand the actual coding experiences
of the uh candidates so these are
various or multiple ways of which the
after the phone screen Things Are very
forward
okay and so
phone screen testing maybe take home
assignment or programming project and
then um
so you get to that point and then
somebody is going to say let's sit down
and talk you're in my office or on more
likely today over Zoom or some other
platform and we're going to
be face to face like you and I are doing
now
who's that first person that the most
technical hires are going to talk to
that a supervisor is that somebody from
HR or is it uh
is it going to be the person you report
to or is it going to be a
another screener
oh it's going to be another screener
because uh after these set of rounds
round there are an HR obviously contacts
you that you have cleared The Rounders
you have not cleared around either via
email or by a phone right so after that
uh communication with HR is done uh then
HR communicates with you to move on to
next uh process which is next set of
interviews basically so either those
interviews can be a DSA algorithm or
they can be a system design or for
front-end roles it can be a front-end
based interview and uh likewise so the
process varies for different companies
accordingly yeah so yeah go ahead a
child's person who communicates with you
throughout from the starting till the
end about uh the feedback about the
interview scheduling about the results
everything
and that the slang term some people use
for that is they act as a sherpa who
guides you through the process
um but the the that first interview face
to face with a technical screener
yeah and they're going to be asking you
about your knowledge of the domain but
about the industry domain but the the
technology domain about your skills your
experience but also
as you said they're going to be asking
probing questions about
um you know
how much do you really know about the
area
um and
again maybe more things like
uh
if we have this kind of a design problem
how would you tackle it or how would you
approach it what are the important
things that you would tease out of it
right exactly exactly that's right
okay
um so go ahead
so in these technical rounds uh one
thing that I want to highlight is that
they try to gauge your uh even if you
are a fresher right they try to gauge
your thought process you know like uh
somebody can just bluntly say that I
don't know this I've never dealt with
this kind of situation but somebody else
on the other hand might keep on trying
and you know a brain stop while the
interview is going on even if they don't
have much exposure so uh even if wire if
it's freshers of or it is uh uh you know
lateral hires it's always about they're
trying to gauge your experience your
Tech exposure your thought processes so
that is what actually they screen you
for
yep
and the
they're looking for your your
essentially engineering shops as you
might say that the the uh skills
knowledge and approach that you take
technical side
um how many times would you go through
that process and with that same
employer for that opportunity how many
uh technical rounds might there be
you've gone through that first one is
there going to be another one where
somebody is going to ask deeper
questions or more direct questions about
the work that you'd be doing
uh so about the work that I would be
doing that comes towards the end
basically and first your Tech skills and
your behavioral interviews uh are taking
place uh so I think uh on an average
there are uh three to four rounds of
interviews in most of the companies on
an average yeah
so after that first text screening do
you move straight to a behavioral or
that would be technical interviews first
and once you clear the technical
interviews you'll have a behavioral or
in place of that you will have a call
with hiring manager who would basically
understand or ask you questions about
behavioral related questions plus about
your other experiences either at college
level or at uh you know uh previous
company so that is the hiring manager
around or you can say uh behavioral
round yeah and
behavioral is really important we talk
about uh soft skills and you you want to
be able to fit in with the the team and
the culture so
it's not you know it could be the most
technically proficient engineer most
productive but if you can't work with
the rest of your team and
can't follow the direction properly and
things like that
it's not likely you're going to get
hired and if you do you're going to be
put into a back office someplace where
um people will eventually slip you
assignments under the door and but you
work on them independently because you
don't work well with others so uh
it's important for people to know that
they need to be able to interact with
people they need to be able to be
personable
they need to show that they're
team players
and that they're capable of taking
Direction and even criticism
so that they can improve
but that all comes in that behavioral
round of interviews right those are
those are the kinds of things people
will probe for yes yes I think
um
so you've gotten through the
technical screening they're confident
that you can
handled the technical aspects of the job
you've gotten through the behavioral
screening and they feel that your person
who can work well as part of their team
what's the final round of interviews
that would face in that
situation what's the last thing before
you're hired
I think behavioral round or the hiring
manager round usually has been the last
round of interviews uh in um like almost
99 percent of the companies that I
interviewed for and once I think that is
established because technical is taken
care of first and then later on
Behavioral or hiring manage around and
if that's a thumbs up then they move
forward with you know uh discussing
about uh other aspects like you know
benefits salary and everything else and
the HR informs you that you've been
selected and the joining date and every
other formalities are taken care in or
taken care of later on yeah and and that
that last part of the process where
you're talking about
you know benefit salary that type of
thing that's an opportunity for you as
the prospective employee to
um kind of interview
the other side of the table by by asking
you know
what are the options what negotiate a
bit in terms of you know what is the
salary range or what what you know can
we trade off
the benefits for for salary or things
like that or and also to find out what
your career path within the company is
going to be so yeah you you need to be
respectful when you're going through
that right but you need to also not be
too shy to ask the question yeah yeah
yeah
so uh usually those conversations happen
with the HR and not with the interviewer
so uh HR is the person who communicates
back and forth regarding these uh
benefits or they inform you about the
benefits about the salary negotiations
about uh any other aspects as well right
like uh if you're getting stock rewards
any joining bonuses anything so they are
the ones who carry on this formalities
so uh yeah so I think HR is the point of
contact for you for after your process
is completed basically and apart from uh
these benefits salary negotiations I
just want to point out that at every
every interview whether it is technical
whether it is behavioral at the end of
the interview always I think it's a good
thing to ask questions you know most
importantly because not only you're
trying to uh understand where you will
be working but you need to understand
how the interviewer's experience has
been working in that company you know
and what are the Technologies they work
on what are the things that every how
does their day-to-day life look like in
that working in that company and in the
hiring manager round or behavioral round
you can basically understand what are
the how is the culture of the company
right you can gauge on inside uh because
you're speaking to somebody who's
directly working in that company right
so you can understand the insights about
the culture of the company the technical
uh Tech stack of the company about the
team's culture if you know the hiring
manager if you're having an interview
and uh you get a better understanding
because the HR is just a point of of
contact for you to get into the company
but within a company also you'll be
working in a team or a tech stack or a
particular product and these
understandings you can get uh by asking
questions with the interviewers and the
hiring manager
and that
that's very important one question you
should never ask however is what is it
you do you know what is it that this
company does yeah
definitely not I think so yeah
definitely not because one of the uh I
mean I wanted to come into some of the
interviewing tips actually and the top
most uh I think in an agenda we had like
what makes you stand out while
interviewing right so one of the things
um I mean I'm not going to say all of it
right now but just one of the topmost
things is you should know where you are
interviewing you know the company that
you are interviewing for you should be
proactive about researching about that
company about the role because it shows
that you're interested it shows that you
know you've put in efforts to understand
about the company so like you said don't
ask what the company does it's a
straight rejection basically I think so
yeah
yeah if you don't care enough to know
what the company does it's probably not
going to you know they're going to get
the signal that you're not really
interested in the job there yeah exactly
yeah well so as you said we transition
into the tips that you uh
prepared for our audience today so can
you go through some of those
right uh so some of the things that
actually make you stand out as an
interviewee is that obviously one thing
that I've covered is you need to prepare
you need to understand as a fresher also
you know when companies come in colleges
and they give you a presentation as to
what the company does and everything be
attentive in those presentations uh ask
questions if you can because uh it shows
that you're interested you know and be
attentive about it and also when you are
you know uh interviewing as a lateral
hire or uh like on site like online
basically so
um try to understand about the role that
you're interviewing for try to
understand about the company or what the
company does or if you know about the
product as well try to be proactive you
know about these so that you can ask
questions about uh this while you're
interviewing because at the end of the
interviews always the interviewer will
ask you if you have any questions and I
think definitely you should ask
questions that is also one another thing
that makes you stand out like you
shouldn't be like I don't have any
questions because if you're interested
you would be attentive about and you
would have some questions right how
things work how's your daily life at
this company what is the best uh way or
like what is some of the best uh things
that you've worked on in the company and
everything basically right so I think I
have tried that and it's worked out
pretty well another thing is that um
I think now as an interviewee I'm
talking but uh as an interviewer at my
company I have interviewed many
candidates as well right so one of the
most important thing that I look out for
is
um bias for Action bias for Action is
basically that if I give you a problem
statement uh and you don't have any idea
about it and it has happened with me
multiple times at College as well and it
was like for Morgan Stanley only
basically I didn't know anything about
the problem statement but I kept on
trying for 45 minutes again and again
the interviewer will give you hints
every time it is very important to be
attentive to pick up those hints and
keep on trying again and again because
in the middle of the interview if you
say that I don't know about this
everything like that it just shows that
you know you don't try hard enough and
that's where bias for Action comes into
play that bias for Action is that even
if you don't know something but you keep
on trying as per your best knowledge to
keep on attempting you know that problem
statement right so that goes a long way
to show that your attitude is right and
you can be trained for the job basically
so I think that works very well
and it stands out basically yeah
yeah
well
that's really important is that they
want to see
I mean if you if you go to somebody and
you say
I need help with this problem
you don't want them to look at it and
say
you know it's not my it's not my
department or I have no idea what you're
talking about so go go ask someone else
you at least want them to say well let's
take a look at this together see if we
can figure it out
um you know and unless there is a clear
situation where
the person next to me is an expert in
this and you should talk to that person
but if you're you're in a role
um and that's going to be the case in
anybody who's doing this type of
development is that you're going to be
assigned
to solve a problem or Implement
something and if you don't know how to
do it the expectation is that you're
going to take the action that necessary
to figure it out and find out what you
need to learn in order to be able to do
it
does that biased reaction is important
exactly and that's how the interviews
actually structured also you know like
the interviewer won't tell you that you
have to show the result for basically
this problem statement they will give
you a very weight problem statement
whether it be you know front-end problem
or DSA or you know system design
anything it will be pretty vague and
they want you to proactively ask
questions to get better understanding
about the problem statement you know so
they want you to ask questions to
collaborate and some of my interviewers
have actually directly told me that
don't consider this as an interview
consider this as a discussion that we're
working on something basically so that
you know it can be a back and forth and
likewise they are saying that I can
learn from your ideas you can learn from
what I am saying and everything like
that so uh I think that collaborative
efforts it's a two-way street on the
interview you know it's not like they
are just asking you stuff you can ask
them questions as well to get better
understanding about your approach as as
well be very vocal about your thought
process that is another very important
thing that being vocal because if you're
just coding or typing something and we
you are just silent then it just very uh
awkward silence they need to understand
your thought process as well you know so
if you're going wrong they can correct
you or they can guide you or just you
know have that communication that what
are you thinking about you know so that
thought process being vocal about the
thought process helps a lot as well
and you bring up an interesting point
about the two-way conversation
um because in any work real world
working situation
um you basically have a customer that
you're dealing with may not be the End
customer of your company it may be an
internal customer somebody who comes to
you with the problem and wants you to
deliver a solution
um
but
if you don't ask questions as part of
that process
you may not understand what they've
asked of you so if you if yeah if they
come to you with a problem you know I
want you to do this and you say
yes sir and start working on that
you may have developed a solution based
on your imperfect understanding of the
problem so it's always important to show
that you have the skills of listening
and probing for more information so that
when you start work you and your
customer understand together this is
what I'm going to to create and deliver
to solve this problem so that's a really
important thing to demonstrate in your
interviews as well so
um looking at our time here
I think we have time for a little a
couple more
things to talk about before we get to
the Q a but we'll go to the Q a fairly
shortly
um
so
one of the things about questions asking
questions is that if you don't
ask questions
it like you said it is
the indicator that you weren't all that
interested because generally speaking
questions come from your
thinking about mismatches between what
somebody is telling you and what your
expectation is
you know the the interviewer is or the
as you described the situation College
recruiters who are talking about their
company and describing it
um
they're painting a picture of of that
situation a company and what it's like
to work there and your
creating an expectation of what
you would
experience if you were there and so if
you have a mismatch between what it is
you want to be doing and what it is
they're describing or if you don't you
have a doubt about well what about this
aspect of it what about that aspect of
it you really want to highlight that and
bring out that question to show that
you're making that that kind of mental
connection
um it also talked about culture and
early on you said one of the things that
attracted you to GitHub was its
reputation
for uh
a lively and friendly culture
um so in the in the interviewing process
how did you um
elicit information from the interviewers
about
you know whether that impression was
correct and what the culture really was
like there
right oh so one thing I forgot to
mention was like while uh reaching out
for referrals I well I reached out to a
lot of random LinkedIn people as well
like you know I should use to send
connection requests and ask for
referrals and whenever I was uh selected
for a company basically like whenever
you used to have interviews technical
interviews or behavioral round or HR
around the hiring manager rounds towards
the end I used to try to gauge in
understanding how it is working how is
it work for them to work at that
particular company right so uh when for
same applies to GitHub as well that for
the interviews I used to ask like you
know how do they like working over there
what is the best thing how is the
culture how would they describe the
culture as well and after I was selected
as well like I had cleared the
interviews as well I reached out to a
couple of folks on LinkedIn as well like
you know to understand to get their
opinion as well about how their thought
process was about the culture so
um that gave me a better understanding
from multiple sources to formulate like
you know you about the culture
great
um let's go ahead and start taking some
questions here from the audience so we
get time to do a few of those before
we're
out of time but we have
a question from one of our LinkedIn
viewers Kofa
who's from Ethiopia
and
uh
but he's asking
um
asking a question about simply learned
and support for that
um I would point out to you Kofa that we
have a number of different
uh things that we're able to do we don't
give
a scholarships per se but uh we do offer
different things like free courses and
uh to get you some of the basics and
so you might want to look into some of
that
um
for you however uh Kata asks
what do you think is the best type of
course to take to get into software
development
that's kind of a general open-ended
question I'm not sure what I want to say
to that uh yeah it's a very uh General
open-ended question I would say I've
seen people uh who work so just to give
a brief background I prior to software
engineering I was trying I was I'm from
a bio background actually I wanted to
become a doctor and then later on I
moved to software engineering basically
and I have seen people from non-uh
engineering backgrounds also moved to
software engineering jobs as well uh and
that too with a separate like a degree
which is focused on arts or you know
science basically so if you have a
software engineering degree I think most
of the degrees are like uh b-tech mtech
uh I have done MCA and I've seen people
from BC as well you can do any it's just
that uh people who have engineering
Focus degrees uh have more doors open
for them to get into it but people who
are
non-uh engineering background they also
can you know try to do their own
personal projects join boot camps uh you
know join any uh courses or they can do
any personal projects and highlight
their profiles you know like either
GitHub profiles either you know code
Chef profiles or so that the interviewer
can know that you know even you have
that uh Tech you have the technical
knowledge you can have your own
portfolio of projects basically that you
have that technical knowledge and you
can do this technical you can learn
these Technologies and everything from
anywhere basically so
um the thing is that you need to put in
the work even if you're from
non-engineering background and for
engineering I think I mentioned the
degrees and everything I hope that
answers the question yeah
we had a question from Deepa who
asked what technologies are you working
with at GitHub right now okay so
currently I'm working with the golang
react.js uh c-sharp as well and uh I'm
working on the security side of things
actually so that I won't be able to
disclose so far but
yeah but mainly for backend C shop and
golang
and cloud-based Technologies like Azure
and AWS Cloud as well yeah picture
yeah let's see
looking for a
uh
what yeah I'm looking at a shake-assen
interest question
how did you make a good I'll rephrase it
for him
um how do you make a good impression as
a person when you're doing the interview
what are the what are the things that
you should pay attention to to make a
good impression with the interviewer
um I think as I said you need to
research about the company one second
thing confidence and communication
skills I can't stress enough upon this
that you need to have a confident body
language you need to communicate clearly
and uh like you know these things come
obviously you're nervous in the
interviews obviously there's a lot of
stress and pressure to Showcase your uh
skills or your thought process within
that 45 minute or one hour timeline
right that's where you need to train
your mind basically and how this happens
is through mock interviews as well you
can give mock interviews to your friends
or you know you can reach out to folks
to take your mock interviews I gave a
lot of mock interviews and that actually
because when you start talking and uh
you need to talk according to you know
you need to frame your thought process
and then uh formulate it and it has to
be uh communicated in a very crisp
manner right so these all things come
with practice and practice happens in
mock interviews or interviewing for a
lot of companies right so uh again to
summarize you need to be confident you
need to be honest actually and uh you
need to have a clear thought process and
communicate effectively and ask a lot of
questions as well yeah be attentive
about what the interview is saying catch
up the hints and yeah
yep and about 40 years ago there was a
book that was popular in the United
States called Dress for Success yeah
and
its lessons are still applicable in the
sense that you do want to present
yourself in the professional way say you
would prefer not to show up to a even a
video interview and a T-shirt and that
type of thing but
um
those are kind of just basic things that
you'll get from interview practice with
people usually people will tell you yeah
you know it's like that
um
the dish is curious to know if you have
any advice on how to shift from a non-it
domain into I.T
yeah oh so as I said basically you need
to develop a portfolio obviously you
don't have that college or that relevant
experience on your resume but if you
want to move from non-it to it you can
actually start uh upskilling yourself in
those I.T technologies that you are
interested for either it can be front
and full stack back-end Technologies
anything that you are interested for uh
and uh the companies that you want to
apply for you can see what is the
interview process like because every
company has its own process so you can
start preparing for DSA system design
and then basically create a portfolio
like you know your social media presence
would matter more in these cases as well
you know you can add your projects
publicly and showcase that you are
technical you might not be from a
technical background but you have those
technical skills so that's when skills
showcase comments to picture right via
portfolio via public uh social media
posts everything like that and you can
add these portfolio links or project
links and everything in your resume and
then you can reach out to more folks
that you know you have so and so
experience with so and so Technologies
and all that and uh initially the first
uh getting into the first company from a
non-it to it will be tough I'll not like
you know beat around the bush and I'll
just say it it's it is going to be tough
but out of the 200 companies that you'll
apply for probably only two interviews
or three interviews you'll get right but
you need to have that perseverance of uh
breaking through into that company and
once you are into that I.T company right
then you can switch companies you can
you know probably keep interviewing
because you are inside the door now
right so I think showcasing your
portfolios making public portfolio
showcasing your skills publicly and then
perseverance from non-it to it that you
know for the Breakthrough to happen I
think that would probably be I think one
of the ways to go about it
uh we have a question also somebody who
asked about
how do you
overcome a language barrier if you're
um for example English skills aren't
very strong what what advice would you
give to somebody
in that situation
uh then I think you see you know your la
behind in something right and if the
interviews are going to be in that
language right then uh sometimes it
doesn't matter the interviewers don't uh
take that much into consideration if
your technical skills are good if your
behavioral skills are great so they
don't take into consideration but it
definitely adds a plus point of your
communication skills is very you know
good so if you can or groom yourself or
enhance those skills by you know
practicing or taking up a course there
are multiple apps as well which teach
you multiple like language right so uh
you can practice via YouTube videos or
you can practice with your friends or in
mock interviews how to express your
thoughts and basically improve in that
language but uh having said that uh some
of the companies don't take that into
consideration as well they see your
skills they see your behavioral and your
attitude as well and sometimes it is let
go but it is definitely a plus point to
have good communication skills
okay we have an interesting question
um
what is your advice when somebody needs
to respond to an interviewer who says
what are your best positive traits and
what are your negative traits what are
some of the things that you you
think are are good answers to that
um I feel it's important to be honest
about it because the interviewer knows
like what are the standard answers and
if people are just you know voicing out
those so uh I definitely uh showcase
that you know that uh and I think this
question is more about
uh getting uh I mean the interviewer
wants to know whether you are self-aware
about yourself you know whether you know
that what are your positive skills you
can obviously people talk about the
positive skills more and if they ask you
about your negative skills right and if
you know some of I mean be vocal about
some of your negative skills as well a
couple of them and not like a breaking
or complete breakthrough ones but uh
some of the ones which are self-aware
about and if you're self aware about it
you can say that you know this is what
I'm looking to improve on uh you know uh
basically this is my shortcoming or a
negative trade and I'm looking to
improve on it basically so I think this
is one way to go about it because it
makes you it knows it showcases the
interviewer as well that you're
self-aware about your shortcomings as
well and you need Improvement in those
departments
um
and this has to be for it to cut off
actually this has to be relevant to your
uh like job and not like your
yeah
yeah it's like you don't want to say
well my my worst thing is I forget to
feed my cat yeah exactly that's what I
was going
to
um
Aisha asks what what are some of the
questions that
if you can ask when the interviewer says
do you have any questions what are what
kinds of things should uh
candidate be thinking of in terms of the
kinds of questions that are appropriate
to ask
okay also based on your conversation
like what you had with the interviewer
right so you can ask about
um one thing you can ask about if
they're talking about any system design
question you can ask about how you would
have approached this problem you know to
understand like if you can get anything
out of that conversation second thing is
you can understand like what do they
work on in their company I'm in that
company basically right to understand
what is uh and how does the day usually
look like that working in that company
and uh what is there basically get an
understanding about the culture of the
company as well from them and what they
work on and uh how are they liking it
everything and then later on you can ask
questions about uh uh if it is allowed I
mean I've asked for feedback as well if
they can give me any feedback you know
for improvising in anything that they
thought I was lacking in or if they can
if they're allowed to give feedback I
think they do give that and if they're
not then uh probably they skip over it
yeah right
um
so Samuel asks a question do you have to
be skilled in all the technologies that
are in the job description
oh definitely you know I think
definitely no because
um it's that these skills can be taught
you know when you're joining those
skills can be taught and all uh but uh
it's a good thing to have those skills
right but if you're just two three years
experience and there are like seven
eight skills and all so you don't need
to prepare for those Technologies uh
only for that particular interview right
so whatever the interview processes of
that company or try to get an
understanding from the HR or through
other people that what is the process
and prepare for the process and uh I
think that goes to show that you know
you're a keen learner uh I think through
your interviews the interviewers would
gauge if you're a click a keen learner
if you're a quick learner and uh you
know then I think the skills can be
taught as well but sometimes having said
that if it's a non-negotiable skill that
they want to have or and this mostly
applies for senior roles actually uh so
then I think they prefer like not to go
ahead with the candidature
yeah
I just want to mention that I heard a
radio interview recently with an
executive from Accenture here in the
California San Francisco Silicon Valley
area
they were talking about the
fact that so few women apply for cyber
security rules and fed you know we find
a cultural distinction between men and
women where a man will look at a job
description and say oh I have 70 percent
of the things that are on that job
description I'm going to apply and
interviewers saying unfortunately we
find that women often look at the same
situation and say I only have 70 percent
of the things that they require so I'm
not qualified yeah and they they don't
apply so
you should
get back to the phrase you used
previously which is a bias for Action
yeah if you look at a situation where
you think that would be a good job for
me and I have
most of the qualifications you should
always give yourself the benefit of the
doubt apply and see if
look at that situation let them make the
decision let them make the decision you
know and you're on your candidate shirt
um one of the things I wanted to just
point out was like never self-reject
yourself basically you know like
obviously when we are interviewing we
are putting out ourselves out there uh
and obviously there would be rejections
and all but it is not a good idea to
self-reject yourself before the other
person rejects you right so even if yeah
so even if you're not uh feeling that
this role I mean you're thinking that I
don't have these skills and everything
apply for it at least give it a shot
right don't take that shot away from you
don't self reject yourself give it a
shot you'll get learning out of it yeah
yeah that's that's the advice from the
Canadian hockey star Wayne gretzy
Gretzky was you miss 100 of the shots
that you don't take exactly um
a couple last questions uh
uh is asking if you have an opinion on
the best coding language for
the future
uh no I don't actually because I think
it's so uh to each uh their own actually
because uh in some of the cases
sometimes when you're working closer to
the uh Hardware you need like C plus
plus right if you're working uh if you
need just quick Hands-On something to do
and you need multiple Library support
you can use uh python or golang and
golang is a fairly new language and you
can go for you know Java because Java is
used widely in most of the places for
backend and all so uh I don't think
which is the best language or anything
it depends on case to case what problem
you're trying to tackle right if I want
to use Kafka and if Java has better
support for that then I'd probably go
ahead with that so it's it's a thought
process and the use case I think
you can search on YouTube for you know
the animations that show the uh most
popular coding Languages by year
and it's really fascinating to watch you
know what happens from around 1960 to
2020.
and just watch the languages that come
and go and
when I
was at school they were still teaching
Fortran programming and I would
touch decks of Punch Cards in order to
submit my
software homework so
the world keeps changing too fast for
you to get fixated on any particular uh
language as if that's going to be the
final answer for for the for the future
um
and the last question I want to ask gets
back to the point you made about resumes
what advice do you have for folks on
working on their resume and getting it
formatted so it gets past that that AI
screening
gets to the uh manager
so it has to be an atheist friendly
resume or definitely doesn't have to be
a dog it has to be a PDF right because a
non-edible editable format would be
better and uh for freshers I would say
for resume try to Showcase your
um you know like a college projects or
for non-it background also try to
Showcase your side projects or
everything like that if you have any
portfolio GitHub links or uh coding
profile links to at that and offer uh
experienced folks so definitely and like
you know add on your experience and
showcase the experiences and apart from
the tech aspects also try to Showcase
like
um what all you have done apart from
Tech things as well right so if you
volunteer anywhere if you are uh uh
volunteered at your company for any
initiatives that you have taken so I
think those are also good things and if
you're into sports or anything like that
for freshers you can add those things as
well and definitely the resume I'll just
rehydrate has to be ATS friendly and has
to be a non-editable PDF format so that
helps the process basically on
fulfilling the forms automatically and
everything
okay with that I'm going to apologize to
um
all of the people in the audience whose
questions we couldn't get to in the time
allowed but I will um
thank you everybody for for those
questions that we did get to and
um you can always
email me and I can pass on information
like Mike L is in the invitation that
you received for this webinar if you're
on WebEx
um so let's move on and
we're gonna get to the concluding part
of the webinar here
and I'm going to mention a program
one of the programs that we offer here
at simply learn this one happens to be
four people in India expressly because
we don't offer the job guarantee outside
of India
um but we have partnered simple Learners
partnered with a number of hiring
companies who have basically said to us
that they can take on as many people as
we can graduate from this program it's a
six-month comprehensive program
it gives you access to live classes uh
so you take weekly live classes on the
weekends with instructor uh online in a
virtual environment so it's all
delivered online you don't have to
travel anywhere
um you can do your exercises and access
other materials all during the week on
your own schedule 24 7. so it's very
flexible this is the curriculum after
the welcome class you learned
object-oriented programming
um
then study back-end schools and
Technologies
Frameworks and devops and then front end
and
um it culminates in a Capstone project
where you take a problem
statement that is aligned to
um an industry
problem that interests you in a
particular domain you can choose and
then you solved that problem you
developed the full stack
solution and that becomes your final
exam for the the course but it also
gives you something to put into your
GitHub portfolio to show off you can
also take an elective your option no
extra cost or
testing automated testing and devops
so at the end of this process not only
do you get the certificate but in this
particular program you do get a 100 job
guarantee which means
that if you don't get a bona fide job
offer one of our partner companies
within six months after completing the
program
then we will refund all of the course
fees
the 100 refund for uh anyone who doesn't
get a job
however our
placement rate now is running
uh 95 or higher so
this is a really great opportunity for
people who are freshers who want to get
into the field and
um
along the way we will be giving you help
with things like as Puja talked about
resume support
interview crap mock interviews that type
of thing so it's not just we put your
information into a hopper and let people
look at it we also give you the support
and training to help you be a better
candidate so
with that
very very
brief thumbnail sketch of the program
that's not enough information to make a
decision but are you potentially
interested I'll ask this question
audience
is this something that you potentially
interest you in enrolling
and if so when do you think you would
want to start
again
give you about another 20 seconds to
answer
you know that's about 20 seconds too
long but
foreign
about five
or
three
two
one
there we go
about half of our audience is interested
uh we'll give you information about how
to
uh get more
details about the program uh another
quarter or so I might be interested
uh it looks like a substantial number of
folks are interested in doing this
fairly quickly so
let me um
go ahead and put it into the chat as we
say thank you to Puja for being here
with us today
so much for sharing with you with all of
the audience
your expertise your experiences and
we're very grateful for that
thank you Pooja thanks to it thanks a
lot
and uh I've just put into the chat the
information to contact us about the
course and I'm also now putting into the
chat
uh which is LinkedIn
you can reach out to her through that
and
with that I will conclude the webinar by
reminding everyone to keep in touch with
us on our social media channels at
simplylearn on Facebook and Twitter
simply learn on LinkedIn
we hope to see you at future webinars of
this type we put them on
actually several times a week
so keep an eye out for that and we also
hope that we can welcome you into the
simply learned learning community
thank you all for being here
thank you have a nice day